Hey, Thoughty2 here.
The world can be a confusing place sometimes
so, often, many of us try to make sense of
it with our own little routines and rituals,
like always putting on your right shoe first
or locking the door three times to make sure
you don’t forget.
But the amazing thing is how often these habits
and ideas become a full blown superstition,
some of which last for centuries.
So cross your fingers, don’t step on the
cracks, throw some salt over your shoulder
and let’s go look at superstitions from
around the world.
Let’s start in Asia.
The first thing that jumps out is numbers.
In China, 8 is considered lucky, since it
sounds like their word for prosperity.
They really tried to get the most out of it
for the Olympics in Beijing by starting the
opening ceremony at 8 seconds and 8 minutes
past 8pm on 8th August 2008.
By a strange coincidence, in Japan, it also
has the meaning of growing prosperous but
this is because the character for the number
8 (八 hachi) broadens gradually.
By that logic, in English, 8 would mean you’re
going to become a snowman.
But cut that eight in half and you have the
horrible number 4.
Most of Eastern Asia is tetraphobic, meaning
they are scared of 4, due to its similarity
to the word for death.
This is extremely widespread and you’re
unlikely to find buildings with a 4th floor,
goods sold in four-packs or any parking lots
with that digit.
Even numbers like 14 and 24 or ones in their
40s are avoided, excluding 42 of course, I
may have just lost China.
It’s so severe in fact that giving something
to a fellow Asian with the number four in
it can be enough for the police to get involved
since it’s seen as a death threat.
So if you’re ever thinking about buying
property there, guess which house is going
to give you the sweetest deal?
India has an aversion to rounded numbers such
as 100 or 70, and prices are normally taken
up by one rupee to avoid them, a smart bit
of business.
Indians also like to feed milk to snakes,
usually as a religious offering.
Snakes don’t actually drink milk so thousands
die every year due to this practise.
So don’t feed snakes milk.
Also, in Korea, don’t feed your boyfriend
chicken wings as it’s a sign that he will
fly away and leave you.
Whereas in the west, if your partner feeds
you chicken wings it’s usually seen as a
sign that they’re a keeper.
If you’re eating in Japan however, don’t
leave your chopsticks stuck in the rice as
this is reserved for funerals, instead you
should rest them horizontally across the bowl.
If you are at a funeral though, remember to
hide your thumbs or the recently departed
will sneak under your nails and cause your
loved ones to die young, that’s if they
haven’t already been killed by leaving a
fan on whilst they sleep.
Fan death is a very prevalent fear in South
Korea and all fans are sold with a “life-saving”
cut-off timer to prevent you being either
asphyxiated, frozen or boiled to death, depending
on which bit of air conditioning logic you
apply.
No one knows how it all started but there
is an excellent conspiracy theory that the
government made it up during the 1970s energy
crisis.
It would be like combating the California
drought by telling everyone that having a
bath makes you fat.
The Middle East has some of the oldest culture
that exists today so they have a rich tapestry
of myths and legends.
One very common one is the evil eye.
This is a curse than can bring great misfortune
to a person, giving them bad luck, an unhappy
life, or perhaps just a bad dinner or no phone
reception, in very mild cases.
The evil eye can get you at any time, cast
by a hate-filled glare without your knowing.
So how do you protect yourself from this terror?
What you need is a Nazar; an eye shaped amulet,
typically a blue coloured crystal, that can
be worn around your neck, hung above your
door or lost down the back of your sofa.
For non-amulet based protection, you can also
use the phrase “mashallah” which expresses
appreciation and you can try to dress yourself
humbly to avoid the eye’s vicious gaze.
There is a universal protection against all
malicious spirits, not just eye based, called
the Khamsa and it’s just an image of an
open right palm.
Occasionally precious possessions such as
cars are anointed with right hand prints to
make sure they are protected.
There are many superstitions based around
creepy crawlies.
In Qatar, it was once believed that spiders
had the ability to control house fires so
if you killed one, it was like murdering a
tiny firefighter.
The spiders were no help at getting cats out
of trees though so fortunately they kept the
fire department up and running.
Also beetles were a sign that guests are coming
and you should prepare for their arrival.
Welcoming guests and people in need into your
home is actually a big part of Islamic culture.
But they must be careful with their feet,
and not just to avoid crushing your eight-legged
firemen.
A new home must be entered with the right
foot but a bathroom must be entered with the
left.
It’s the household hokey-cokey.
In some areas of Africa, superstitions carry
a lot of weight and are a big part of daily
life, especially when it comes to things like
sickness and success.
Many villages across the continent have a
witch doctor, who will be consulted before
consulting a medical professional.
Some of the cures that are suggested involve
the patient acquiring ingredients such as
the eggs of a snake or the claws of a wild
cat.
I imagine it reduces the amount of people
calling in sick for work, imagine if you needed
to go get some alligator teeth in order to
be written a sick note…um…
no thanks, I’ll be at my desk.
In Sierra Leone, Alhaji Suliaman Kabba runs
the union of traditional healers and one major
area of concern for them are Witch Guns.
These aren’t pointy hatted women holding
firearms like you might be thinking, but a
way of killing with a curse.
According to Kabba “the earliest and deadliest
type of witch gun is made out of the husk
from rice” so beware anyone carrying a bag
of basmati through the airport check in.
Although you don’t need to be on the plane
to do the damage, since the range of these
guns is unlimited.
And although witchcraft is not officially
recognised in the courts, suspects have still
been tried and convicted for these suspicious
killings nevertheless.
Anyone who dies young without an obvious cause
is often thought to be a victim of a witch
gun attack.
And if you can’t find a witch’s gun, then
grab her broomstick, since in Nigeria, it’s
thought that hitting a man with a broom can
cause him to becomes impotent, even making
his entire genitals disappear.
Fortunately, the victim can quickly save himself
if he grabs the broom and returns at least
seven blows to his attacker.
I don’t even want to think about what happens
if you hit someone with a vacuum cleaner.
Speaking of manhood, in order to reach it
within the Maasai tribe in Kenya, the young
boy must head out to the plains and catch
himself a lion, using only a spear.
We come to Europe now and we’ll start with
one of the favourite pastimes; drinking.
From Russian vodka, to German beer and French
wine, the Europeans love to drink.
A report from the World Health Organisation,
published in 2014, showed Belarus leading
the world in alcohol consumption per capita
– with 17.5 litres of alcohol drunk per
person per year.
Just to be clear, that’s pure booze, so
in more realistic terms, that would be equivalent
to about 900 pints of beer, per person, per
year.
In fact, European countries occupy 26 of the
top 30 alcohol consuming nations, with only
Grenada, South Korea, Australia and South
Africa joining in for another round at the
winner’s bar.
So, given Europe’s love of the bottle, there
are plenty of alcoholic superstitions going
around.
In Russia, you should always finish all of
your drink and if it’s a shot, you must
never put it back on the table until it is
empty.
You should clink glasses for each new round
of drinks, unless you’re at a funeral.
If you want to send your friends to their
funeral in Germany, you just have to say cheers,
or “prost” in German, with a glass of
water.
It’s considered very rude in places like
Bavaria, since you are wishing death upon
everyone.
But the Germans often meet up for a drink
down their local, often called a Stammtisch
– meaning regular’s table.
When you walk in, rather than waving to the
group, you should knock on the oak table that
they are sitting around.
Now, as you all know, the devil can’t touch
oak, he has some sort of allergy I believe.
So, to prove you are not the devil, you should
rap on the table.
In France, if you are drinking, you are likely
to be eating too.
They have the generic fear of the number 13,
like much or Europe and the US, but it’s
especially true for a dinner party.
Thirteen guests will mean things turn out
very badly for one unlucky diner.
This is thought to come from Jesus’ last
supper, where Judas turned out to be a traitor.
Any bread on the table should always be the
right way up, since upside down bread is the
bread for the hangman.
In olden France, the bakers didn’t want
to serve the hangmen but the king warned them
that it was either that or they would end
up as toast themselves.
So they picked out the worst bread and turned
it upside down, in disdain for their least
popular customers.
In Denmark, if your dinner party gets drunk
and disorderly and you end up breaking all
the crockery, not to worry, just scrape it
up and save it for the end of December.
On New Year’s Eve, take all your smashed
plates and cups and chuck them at your friend’s
house as a way to break in the New Year.
According to the Danes the more you pelt them
with, the better their next twelve months
will be.
South America has the world’s largest jungle
and river; the Amazon and, as you can imagine
in a place with such a wild abundance of life,
the plants and animals have given rise to
a huge amount of different stories and beliefs.
In Brazil, the river dolphins, or Boto, have
a mystical place in society.
Anyone lost amongst the trees is thought to
have been taken into the water and turned
into a dolphin.
They can’t turn back to human but they can
sneak onto the land, wearing catfish for shoes
and stingrays for hats, and impregnate the
local women.
In Argentina, no one turns into a dolphin
but if you are foolish, and fertile enough,
to have a seventh son; beware.
He will turn into a werewolf.
And it won’t be every full moon that he
changes, rather every Tuesday and Friday specifically,
so he’ll never be able to join that yoga
class.
If you want to un-werewolf him, you’ll need
to get the president to adopt him.
One president who will be of no help though
is Carlos Menem.
The Argentine leader throughout the 90s, his
name is now a curse, so avoid saying it in
public.
In Venezuela, it’s the Jaguars that are
bad luck and you must kill any that you see
lurking around the village.
For good luck though, many South Americans
have a great way of wishing in the New Year.
The key is yellow underwear.
Nothing like a little splash of colour to
get you going for the next 6 months.
However in Chile, beware of the splash, for
if a woman gets her dress wet while she is
washing the clothes, she will end up with
a drunk husband.
Now the US in particular, given its history,
is really a melting pot of superstitions from
around the world.
So, there are some obvious ones that we all
know about but do you know how they came about?
Many people have paraskevi…
paraskevidiki…
they have this (onscreen – paraskevidekatriaphobia)
It’s a fear of Friday the 13th.
Now it’s quite a new superstition, but certainly
older then Sean S Cunningham’s movie from
1980.
It’s probably been around for a couple of
hundred years and is just a combination of
a long held distrust of the number 13 and
the fact that Friday is the day Jesus was
crucified, so not his best day.
Many superstitions such as this one, start
small but spread through a psychological reaction
called the Baader-Meinhof phenomenon, sometimes
called frequency illusion.
Say you meet someone at a party and they tell
you about this old band that they love, which
you’ve never heard of, let’s call them
Superdrive, for example.
Then, the next day, you’re on a train, possibly
hungover thanks to the party, and you see
a guy wearing a t-shirt with Superdrive written
on it.
Is the universe speaking to you?
Is this all an illusion and you’re the star
of your own Truman show?
Are Superdrive investing in a crazy marketing
promotion?
Or just a glitch in the Matrix perhaps?
No, it’s none of this.
The world is full of a vast, unmanageable
amount of data.
You can barely process a tiny fraction of
it.
But what your brain does do incredibly well
is spot patterns and connections.
That’s why you can recognise faces from
different angles and read words that are spelt
incorrectly.
So when you have some new information, your
brain keeps an eye out for anything related
to it.
If you’d seen that t-shirt a day before
or a week or two after, you wouldn’t have
even noticed.
You only noticed it because your friend had
told you about the band the day before.
This is known as the Baader-Meinhof phenomenon.
So how does this relate to superstition?
Well once you think something is unlucky,
like a certain date, you will immediately
remember anything bad that happens to you
and associate it with that day.
So if your date cancels on you on Friday 13th,
it’s all the calendars fault, but if you
spill coffee on yourself on Saturday 14th,
it’s because you are a badly coordinated
moron.
Like Friday 13th, crossing your fingers is
also Christian in origin since anything with
the shape of the cross was considered a good
thing.
And in fact, it could have started in a different
form, very early on in the history of Christianity.
Now back in the day, around the time of the
Roman Empire, Christians were not exactly
everyone’s favourite and they would often
be sent off as a snack for the lions.
So, in order to identify a fellow Christian,
there was a kind of secret handshake that
involved forming a cross with another’s
outstretched finger.
And finally, probably one of the most common
superstitions around the world is that breaking
a mirror will bring you bad luck.
This springs from the times of the Romans,
who were the first people to create glass
mirrors.
It was thought that your reflection contained
a little piece of your soul so if the mirror
broke, not only was your soul disfigured,
but it was also trapped in its shiny cage.
The association with seven years of bad luck,
is due to the Roman idea that your body renews
itself every seven years so you had to wait
it out till you grew whole again.
We all have our own ways of making sense of
the world and there’s nothing wrong with
the odd ritual and superstition to get you
through the day.
But if you can’t leave the house without
wearing your lucky pants, carrying a horseshoe
and a rabbit’s foot, and breaking a wishbone
every 7 minutes then I’m afraid bad luck
has already struck; because you’re clearly
mental.